bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7 8 l'actu
sur TV phil78 en ce 12 juin voici
quelques-uns des sujets qui seront
développés en direct comme toujours à
18h la Coupe du monde de football débute
ce soir la communauté brésilienne est
prête rencontre avec des passionnés dans
les Yvelines qui ne manqueront pas un
seul match de cette compétition
plusieurs maisons d'arrêt bloquées par
les surveillants aujourd'hui en France
situation plutôt calme Bois-d'Arcy mais
là aussi le personnel de monde des
moyens elle la contestation ne faiblit
pas depuis le 6 mai dernier alors jade
le maire de La Verrière invité de cette
édition il se dit t'inquiet de
l'évolution de la République vous
entendrez son témoignage il entend
permettre un renouveau citoyen il sera
fixé sur son sort le 26 juin prochain
mes dinouche le principal suspect dans
la tuerie du musée juif de Bruxelles en
mai dernier sera dans une dizaine de
jours s'il est extradé vers la Belgique
ou non ce matin la chambre d'instruction
de la cour d'appel de Versailles amis sa
décision délibérée le suspect toujours
présumé innocent selon son avocat pose
désormais des conditions à son
il dit ceci il demande aujourd'hui aux
autorités françaises de Louis garantir
que la Belgique qui aujourd'hui demande
son sa remise dans le cas de ce mandat
d'arrêt qu'il n'y aura pas et tradition
vers un autre pays c'est la seule
demande que nous avons mais pour
l'instant on attend la décision qui sera
qui sera notifiée et si le 26 juin la
chambre d'instruction confirme cette
demande d'extradition vers la Belgique
l'avocat de Médine mouchera trois jours
pour former un pour roi pour vous en
cassation et suite à ce pour voir un
délai de 40 jours est accordé si la Cour
valide une nouvelle fois la décision la
justice française aura une dizaine de
jours pour organiser le transfert pour
l'instant made in mouche qui reste
incarcéré à la prison de Bois-d'Arcy
suite à l'adoption en première lecture
de la réforme pénale par les députés ce
mardi le syndicat de l'administration
pénitentiaire
Ufap UNSA organisée aujourd'hui une
mobilisation nationale mobilisation
reprise à la maison d'arrêt de
Bois-d'Arcy justement ou des tracts ont
été distribués aux salariés objectif
jamais le recrutement de personnel dans
un établissement qui souffre de
surpopulation de 180% à la mise en place
d'une prime d'affectation ou encore la
rénovation de la maison d'arrêt vieille
de 40 ans font partie des revendications
aujourd'hui elle gère environ entre 100
et 120 dossiers par personne vous voulez
que les accompagnent les gens comment
dans la réalisation c'est pas possible
il faut un recrutement massif de au
niveau à leur niveau il faut recrutement
massif du personnel de surveillance et
les collègues aujourd'hui ce qu'ils
voient c'est surtout le manque de
personnel dans la fonction au niveau des
établissements pénitentiaires par
exemple à Bois-d'Arcy si vous voulez on
a une nouvelle promo qui est arrivé au
deux nouvelles promos de surveillance
qui est arrivé aux 2 juin ils sont 35
aux environs du 20 juin ils seront
opérationnels mais malgré ça il manquera
quand même 31 agents sur la maison
d'arrêt de Bois-d'Arcy qui n'ont pas été
remplacés
ça déjà ça pose un problème
perpétuer la mémoire de la Résistance et
de l'acte déportation l'objectif d'un
prix initié en 1961 par l'ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale Lucien
paye dans le département 8 collèges 9
lycées ont participé cette année elle
est lauréats qui vont maintenant
défendre leurs projets devant un jury
national ce sera à l'automne
devoir individuel ou travail collectif
si la forme changeait en fonction du
niveau scolaire des participants la
thématique était la même libération des
camps nazis autour des déportés et
découvertes de l'univers
concentrationnaire collégien et lycéens
de 17 établissements Yvelines ont
défendu leur projet pour cette édition
2014 du concours départemental de la
Résistance et de la Déportation on a
beaucoup épaulé ce concours au fil des
années parce qu'il est il permet de
rencontrer des acteurs encore vivants
pour nous c'est comment dire une sorte
de symbole de ce que l'école doit être
école de la République puisque
l'autorise par ce concours mais aussi
par d'autres moments de leur vie elle
autorise à se poser des questions sur
son histoire et sur la place qu'on va
trouver quand on sera citoyen dans notre
beau pays et dans l'Europe
des établissements de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye plaisir
Saint-Cyr-l'École se sont distingués
devant le jury composé de membres de
l'éducation nationale et d'associations
de mémoire parmi les lauréats Amaury
lycéens Versailles c'est une période de
l'histoire que j'ai déjà abordé
plusieurs fois sous différents angles et
le concours était pour moi une façon de
d'y trouver un sens un sens plus profond
que le que des combats ce qui m'a le
plus marqué qui me sensibilise le plus
c'est le débarquement du 6 juin parce
que dans tout justement dans les
musiques j'ai vu dans les reportages et
même dans les livres qu'on voit on voit
que c'est un moment où on sent que c'est
très fort émotion pour pour dans tout
dans tout le monde c'est important et
sache combien
le fait d'avoir été occupé et douloureux
difficile insupportable pourquoi surtout
certains résistants sont justement en
vrai dans la résistance pour ne pas
avoir cette occupant sur notre
territoire et pour la liberté de la
France
les laurésilois prépare maintenant
l'ultime étape de ce prix la finale
nationale se tiendra à l'automne
le soleil qui revient et avec les beaux
jours l'envie de jardiner pourquoi pas
de se lancer dans des nouveautés la
permaculture par exemple c'est une
méthode qui permet d'intégrer activité
humaine et écosystème des ateliers pour
initier pour s'initier sont proposés
régulièrement à la Maison de
l'environnement c'est à 50 ans en
Yvelines à Magny-les-Hameaux plus
précisément où l'on retrouve Olivier
Maniscalco
harmoniser l'activité humaine avec
l'écosystème tel est le principe de la
permaculture que l'association Sky en
transition permettait de découvrir lors
d'un atelier ce mois-ci à
Magny-les-Hameaux utilisez des poules
pour réguler la population d'insectes
nuisibles à votre potager se servir de
leurs excréments comme engrais pour
enrichir vos sols les techniques durable
ne manquent pas en permaculture
de façon vraiment très très personnel
dans son jardin sa maison chez soi 31
de la façon dont on va récupérer de
Dupuis à la maison d'abord initié via un
cours théorique les participants étaient
ensuite amenés sur le terrain pour
découvrir comment appliquer la
permaculture à l'échelle d'une ville
nos besoins en tant qu'être humain sont
importants
donc on peut parler de besoins de tout
le monde et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
pour que des besoins de tout le monde
soit un peu mieux
soit bien rempli en fait on n'a pas
envie de se poser à la façon dont on
monte tourne aujourd'hui on a tout
simplement envie
de mieux de mieux trouver sa place et de
jouer un rôle sur notre territoire au
niveau local dans mon potager j'évite de
labourer je laboure pas j'essaie de
conserver les semis enfin je fais mes
semis je conserve les graines tout ça
donc il y a une idée de permanence et
puis j'essaie de déménager des espaces
différenciés dans le potager donc
vraiment ce qu'on a
enfin l'idée un peu de la permaculture
si vous souhaitez découvrir la
permaculture d'autres ateliers seront
organisés prochainement sachez aussi
qu'un jardin pédagogique développé en
permaculture existe à la ferme de
pulloyers et qu'il est possible de le
visiter
invité du journal à présent Alain Hajjaj
le maire communiste de la verrière en
poste depuis 2012 élus en mars dernier
scrutin municipal bonsoir et bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes venu ce soir
car depuis votre commune de 6000
habitants vous vous dites inquiet
inquiet de l'évolution de la République
du rejet et des craintes des citoyens se
sont votes que vous avez employés dans
un communiqué publié au lendemain des
élections européennes dans votre ville
le Front National est arrivé la deuxième
à ces élections on va revoir le tableau
des résultats justement cette vote
d'écart seulement avec le fond de gauche
qui termine en tête comment vous avez
vécu ce moment quand vous avez pris
connaissance de ces résultats déjà de
l'abstention qui a été très forte et
puis de cet écart de cette voix
seulement entre le Front de gauche et le
Front national écouter d'abord
on était en lien avec tous les résultats
nationaux donc on voyait bien que et on
pourrait être franc c'est pas vraiment
une surprise on pressentait qu'un choc
allait se produire et ce choc s'est
produit donc avec effectivement un Front
national très haut une abstention très
forte notamment dans les quartiers
populaires
une désaffections d'évidence de
l'électorat de gauche principalement
mais aussi de l'électorat de droite une
radicalisation pour partie de cet
électorat mais aussi de classe moyenne
qui est sans doute inquiète et donc un
résultat que l'on a vu dans notre
commune dans les communes environnantes
même si on tout petit bout de
satisfaction de communes ont placé la
gauche en tête dans le département deux
seules communes de la verrière
aiguillancourt et la verrière le franc
de gauche mais on peut pas satisfaire
évidemment de ça d'être devant quand il
y a aussi peu d'écartré donc c'est
effectivement un résultat extrêmement
inquiétant mais vous dites c'était
prévisible ça veut dire aussi que sur le
terrain vous le sentez dans les rapports
des gens avec les structures de l'État
ou même dans le rapport des communautés
entre elles aussi il y a cette cette
radicalisation se durcissement de
l'opinion moi j'avais interpellé les
pouvoirs publics et le Premier ministre
qui m'avertu à l'époque en juillet de
l'année dernière en disant effectivement
et j'avais déjà interpellé en disant
notre République c'est pas la République
c'est pas les quartiers qui s'éloignent
de la République c'est la République qui
s'éloigne de nos villes de nos quartiers
il y a un vrai souci de de de
rapport à la représentation démocratique
nos citoyens n'ont plus confiance dans
leurs élites n'ont plus confiance dans
leur partie il y a une désaffection
vis-à-vis des syndicats et donc
évidemment là-dessus se forme de ces
regroupements autour des rejets et le
Front National qui est un parti
évidemment d'exclusion ouvertement
racistes capitalise des voix sur une
abstention forte en nombre de voix la
verrière c'est le Front national c'est
pas c'est pas beaucoup de voir
évidemment 150 voix sur un taux de
participation normale c'est 7 8% donc on
n'est pas sur un chiffre en voie mais
évidemment le symbole est très fort et
donc effectivement nos citoyens
aujourd'hui
s'opposent sans fractionnés
et puis donc
très souvent préfère l'abstention ou
préfère des votes chocs pour interpeller
sans doute les les les
hommes politiques dont nous dont moi
mère de cette ville vous avez rappelé la
situation de l'année dernière avec ses
émeutes qui s'étaient déroulées sur trap
notamment sur la verrière en particulier
aussi une telle situation peut se
reproduire cet été bien sûr vous
constatez le même climat aujourd'hui
bien sûr vous savez le climat il est lié
à trois phénomènes que l'on rencontre et
que tous les maires connaissent bien le
premier c'est le chômage un taux de
chômage un taux désœuvrement extrêmement
important dans des catégories de plus en
plus larges c'est pas que le chômage des
jeunes c'est des personnes qui ont 30
ans qui ont peu travaillé des gens qui
ont 40 ans qui ont pas beaucoup
travaillé avec des fins de droit et donc
toute une génération qui se forme dans
le désœuvrement la deuxième deuxième
élément c'est la perte des références et
des valeurs on est quand même dans une
société aujourd'hui terrible du point de
vue de ce qu'elle véhicule en terme de
valeur la corruption mensonge non
confiances détournement d'argent il
suffit d'écouter les les chaînes et les
télévisions pour entendre ça donc on ne
peut pas forger un monde d'avenir sur
des valeurs qui sont aujourd'hui
bafouées tout ça aussi alors comment on
fait je crois qu'il y a ce renouveau et
on a bien entendu le constat dramatique
que vous faites mais passez le constat
deux choses il me semble il faut
effectivement redonner la parole aux
citoyens moi je pense qu'il y en a marre
de des gens non marre de que les
politiques s'arrochent tous les droits
toutes les pensées le droit de penser et
donc il faut redonner la parole aux
citoyens remettre les citoyens au centre
des débats à la verrière en ce moment
par exemple sur une de nos cités il y a
un collectif d'habitants qui a décidé de
se prendre en charge d'interpeller la
ville d'interpeller bailleur ils font
des réunions avec 50 60 80 participants
il y a voilà il y a pas de politique
mais voilà ils ont décidé de prendre
leurs affaires en main donc c'est
possible c'est possible à un moment
donné que les citoyens se prennent en
charge et faut rompre avec ce système de
pensée unique qui qui dit aux gens il y
a rien à faire c'est la crise ces
révolat ceinture toujours les mêmes
entre parenthèses que voit les citoyens
il voit les écarts se creuser il suffit
de regarder la télévision il suffit de
lire il y a la Coupe du monde de
football en ce moment il suffit de voir
comment vivre un certain nombre de
personnes on sait bien que les écarts se
sont creusés entre ceux qui sont pauvres
toujours plus pauvres et ceux qui sont
riches toujours plus riches et ça on
peut essayer de l'habiller comme on veut
on peut dire que il y a pas d'argent les
gens savent bien là faut faire des
cahiers de doléances oui moi je suis un
petit peu tout ça parce que vous appelez
justement à vous réunir à débattre ça va
prendre quelle forme sur la ville moi je
pense qu'on peut proposer deux trois
choses après les citoyens feront ce
qu'ils souhaiteront et puis chacun se
sent saisira peut-être différemment moi
je dis faux il faut effectivement un
renouveau des idées renouveau des
méthodes renouveau des personnes
politiques et donc il faut effectivement
redonner la la parole et les citoyens
font revenir effectivement comme à une
époque on écrit des cahiers on dit ce
qu'on a à dire
révolution c'est pas le terme je pense
que surtout il faut bouger les choses il
faut que les citoyens nous bousculent il
faut que on nous renvoie aux réalités il
faut que nous reprenions ces réalités
bien en compte et qu'on puisse définir
et il y a peut-être une autre société
possible il y a effectivement moi j'y
crois je crois une autre société qui
sont pas basée sur le consumérisme qui
soit pas basé sur la compétitivité
outrance sur un système économique qui
enrichit ceux qui ont l'argent et qui
appauvri ceux qui n'en n'ont pas je
pense qu'il y a un autre et sur la base
des valeurs les valeurs essentielles qui
restent que l'homme doit trouver sa
place dans cette société sur cette terre
en harmonie avec l'environnement mais
aussi avec les hommes eux-mêmes et ça
c'est possible la dernière cote de
popularité du président de la République
est autour de 15% il doit faire quoi
aujourd'hui dans une telle situation
nous souhaiteriez des nouvelles
élections une des solutions justement ça
redonnerait la parole au peuple moi je
suis pas sûr de cela je pense qu'il faut
commencer par le début c'est-à-dire
redonner confiance dans la citoyenneté
parce que sinon demain ça sera peut-être
pas lui ça sera un autre qui fera à peu
près la même chose donc le débat
aujourd'hui c'est pas est-ce qu'il faut
changer François par Hollande ou
Hollande par François c'est vraiment
changer les méthodes profondément et le
projet et donc il faut commencer par la
base il faut que les citoyens se
mobilisent dans le quartier je prendrai
des initiatives à La Verrière je propose
de redonner la parole aussi citoyens la
verrière il se réuniront ils diront ce
qu'ils ont envie de dire ils écriront
les cahiers de doléances qui et j'espère
que dans chaque ville après les choses
pourront se passer puis que les citoyens
qui ont envie que les choses bougent se
retrouveront dans des forums dans des
débats et qu'on soit un peu bousculé
donc vous adapterez votre politique sur
ce mandat en fonction des remontées que
vous pourrez avoir de ces cahiers
doléances c'est ce qu'on fait déjà c'est
ce qu'on fait moi je suis effectivement
sans arrêt dans des postures d'écoute
c'est difficile parce que le maire
aujourd'hui a moins de moyens qu'il en
avait les budgets sont extrêmement
difficiles et donc les demandes sont
énormes des habitants énormes quels sont
les demandes prioritaires d'emploi et le
logement l'emploi le logement mais
vraiment j'étais encore ce matin dans le
quartier du Bois de l'étang et j'ai
croisé tout un ensemble de jeunes et de
moins jeunes et tous me disent l'emploi
Monsieur le Maire l'emploi quand je leur
dis oui mais le maire il fait ce qu'il
peut il essaie de créer il essaie de
soutenir on voit bien qu'il y a une
dimension autre qu'il faut trouver et
l'emploi et la priorité il faut arrêter
de dire qu'on ne peut pas créer d'emploi
il faut pouvoir créer des emplois des
emplois de production des emplois de
service des emplois qualifiés des
emplois moins qualifiés et il faut
redonner de l'espoir et redonner de
l'espoir c'est redonner des perspectives
c'est aussi redonner des évolutions on
peut commencer peut-être un bout de la
chaîne et puis remonter c'est bien la
femme ascenseur social qui est
complètement en panne aujourd'hui on a
construit des générations là-dessus on
passait d'un petit logement un plus
grand on passait d'un petit emploi non
qualifié un emploi qualifié il y avait
la formation derrière et bien ce système
là faut le remettre un peu en marche et
c'est possible le chômage aujourd'hui
sur la population de La Verrière ça
représente quoi les chiffres officiels
tournent autour de 14 15 malheureusement
il y a aussi plein de gens qui
aujourd'hui s'inscrivent même plus qui
sont au bout de droit définitif donc il
y a toute cette partie de la population
non visible complètement exclue et il y
a une population qui m'inquiète qui est
la population déscolarisée qui rentre
dans aucun chiffre les jeunes de 15 ans
16 ans 17 ans 18 ans et que l'on voit
aujourd'hui dans nos cités c'est pas la
meilleure école de la réussite et de la
vie et cela il faut avoir un message
fort en leur direction il faut pouvoir
leur redonner de l'espoir de l'espérance
de la vigne autre sujet on va parler de
football dans quelques instants il y a
l'ouverture de la Coupe du Monde
forcément c'est un événement toujours
très fédérateur c'est ce qu'on dit
souvent vous y croyez un nouvel effet
fédérateur en France comme en 98 non non
parce que je pense que les
préoccupations beaucoup bougées
bien sûr il y aura de l'engouement bien
sûr selon les résultats des équipes ou
de l'équipe nationale l'engouement
grandira mais je ne crois pas dans le
même contexte
je crois pas au-delà de ces
considérations sur l'état des lieux que
vous faites sur la société comment se
passe le début de ce mandat bien bien
actif vous savez qu'on avait beaucoup de
projets donc on s'est remis au travail
sur les projets que nous avions un peu
mis en sommeil non pas en sommeil nos
ralentit pendant la campagne électorale
donc la réforme des rythmes scolaires
j'étais ce matin la conférence de presse
de Benoît Hamon donc pour faire un
premier bilan on a entendu le ministre
faire un premier bilan donc nous on va
rentrer au mois de septembre le quartier
le projet quartier-gargan dont on va
avoir les premières c'est ce qui se
avant le début de l'été donc les élus
vont pouvoir commencer à regarder ce
projet et puis d'autres encore sur
lequel nous travaillons donc un mandat
actif mais au cœur encore une fois au
cœur la citoyenneté c'est la première
chose dont nous sommes saisis c'est
comment mettre en place les formes de
dialogue de de rencontres régulières
d'interpellation que peuvent avoir les
habitants des élus il faut que les élus
puissent rendre compte régulièrement de
langues moi je suis pour même là
l'aspect révocable du mandat une
dernière question concernant votre
opposition qui vous a reproché sur ce
début de demanda d'augmenter les impôts
vous avez une réponse à oui bien sûr on
n'avait pas augmenté les impôts depuis
10 ans on a augmenté de
1,5%, les impôts donc en disant nous
avons augmenté d'un virgule cinq je
crois que c'est le plus faible taux
d'augmentation toute l'agglomération
ça représente en moyenne 4 euros par
famille donc bien sûr à un moment donné
il faut que les élus prennent aussi leur
responsabilités nous allons continuer
nous sommes inquiets sur le devenir de
la géographie prioritaire nous sommes
inquiets sur les baisses des dotations
et donc évidemment ça ne doit pas se
traduire par la récupération par l'impôt
il faut évidemment que nous regardions
les dépenses des recettes nouvelles le
développement de la ville auquel je
crois merci Alain de la verrière qui est
vous nous avez expliqué un état de la
République aujourd'hui votre vision
aujourd'hui de la situation Merci à VOUS
football donc avec l'ouverture de la du
Mondial ce soir sera donné le coup
d'envoi de cette Coupe du monde avec le
match Brésil Croatie une rencontre
attendue avec impatience pour certains
cinq continents qui tirent leurs racines
de ce pays du football Anthony reycher
Juliette pousseau
bonjour
depuis quelques jours mettre toucher ce
repasse les grands moments de l'histoire
de la Coupe du monde il va vivre le
premier match du Brésil ici à 50 ans en
Yvelines mais ce professeur de capoeira
part avec sa femme et ses deux enfants
pour Bello horizonté sa ville natale le
26 juin prochain pour les 8e de finale
pour moi j'étais petit voilà pour voir
les autres contes du monde ça c'est ça
n'a rien à voir comme c'est aujourd'hui
pendant que brésilien et en fait par
exactement comme brésilien mais on pense
que comme tout la pragnette les entrant
d'y aller et visiter et voir cette coupe
du monde que ça sera exactement
extraordinaire le Brésil organise sa
seconde coupe du monde après celle de
1950 si à l'époque Lassel et Sao s'était
inclinée de Buzyn face à l'Uruguay en
2014 se supportèrent ne voit qu'une
seule fin pour les coéquipiers de Neymar
la star barcelonaise
donc mais je pense pas que c'était que
lui il y a des autres aussi derrière lui
qui sont durs genre et qui vont donner
cette cette présidence
des sorties bancaires de cette coupe du
monde si maître touché vibrera pour
lasser les Sao il aura un œil sur le
parcours des Bleus mais en cas de finale
Brésil France il a déjà choisi son camp
Brésil pourquoi pas
comme j'ai dit
que c'est le Brésil c'est dans notre
pays
mais pour cela là c'est les Sao devra
bien débuter ce soir lors du match
d'ouverture face à la Croatie
mondiale de foot toujours avec ce tour
de force technologique un paraplégique
va en effet donner le coup d'envoi de la
compétition à Sao Paulo grâce à un
exosquelette fabriqué dans les Yvelines
c'est la société BIA une PME de 80
personnes installées à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine qui a travaillé
sur ce dispositif pendant un an avec
plus de 150 chercheurs du monde entier
un exosquelette autonome capable de
redonner à handicapé à des membres
inférieurs la possibilité de marcher à
nouveau en commandant la machine par sa
seule pensée on reste dans le domaine
médical une clinique privée de soins de
suite va voir le jour à Guyancourt en
2017 une clinique qui devrait permettre
d'offrir à une centaine de lits elle
sera installée dans le quartier du Pont
du routoir Catherine zolato et Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude
sur ce terrain de cinq hectares en
bordure du boulevard du château à
Guyancourt une école est en train d'être
construite un programme bientôt complété
par 200 logements et dans deux ans et
demi par une clinique de soins de suite
un bâtiment de côté d'une centaine de
lit longue durée et de 30 litres
d'hospitalisation de jour ainsi que d'un
service à domicile le chantier devrait
démarrer fin 2014 pour une ouverture
prévue en 2017 un projet 100% privé
c'est une clinique de soins de suite
vous savez quand on a été hospitalisé
par exemple suite à une opération on
peut avoir besoin de rester en milieu
hospitalier c'est donc la clinique de
soins de suite qui comprendra une
centaine de lits pour rester y compris
la nuit enfin à temps plein mais
également un hôpital de jour pour les
soins en journée et en plus un troisième
volet c'est l'hospitalisation à domicile
un service de l'hospitalisation à
domicile qui aura sa base et qui
permettra de rayonner pour Guyancourt
mais également pour les communes
avoisinantes pour le sud-yvelines
l'ouverture de cette clinique devrait
générer une centaine d'emplois et puis
toujours à Guyancourt la maison de
retraite des saules qui compte
actuellement en 78 lits va connaître une
extension elle va accueillir 28 litres
supplémentaires qui seront réservés à
des malades d'Alzheimer les travaux
devraient démarrer en septembre 2014
pour une durée d'environ un an et demi
la maison de retraite est gérée par le
groupe Korian déjà gestionnaire de la
résidence Quieta à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux
les cheminots ont voté la reconduction
de la grève pour ce vendredi 13 juin
dans les Yvelines le syndicat CGT a
également suivi le mouvement un cheminot
sur deux est en grève et selon le
responsable syndical de Versailles 51
personnel roulant était en grève
mercredi ils étaient 69 ce jeudi le
trafic qui est donc perturbé aujourd'hui
par exemple sur la ligne SNCF la
verrière Montparnasse un train circuler
toutes les demi-heur aux heures de
pointe idem pour la verrière la défense
sur la ligne C du RER entre 50 ans en
Yvelines et Paris un train toutes les
heures à partir de 8h au départ de
l'agglomération pour les prochains jours
tous les renseignements sont sur le site
qui s'est affiché a baisser des
trains.com fin du journal pour ce jeudi
12 juin demain vendredi vous avez
rendez-vous avec Catherine zulato pour
un nouveau point sur l'actualité locale
excellente soirée et bon match si vous
suivez la Coupe du monde